in genere sul sughero attacchi le foto
di quando sei piccolo quando attacchi la
foto di queste persone bellissime se la
spiral solutions five news awards questa
volta non ho capito una sega di colore
detto madonna ma anche un film di
spielberg non mi senti non avete già la
pelle d'oca a caso è partito era un
horror è diventato re e povia vieni qua
madonna gesù cristo dio allah non so
perché si scusa scorso le nuovole stato
0,3 secondi cosa succede parla mogli
segue
[Musica]
cosa succede sto malissimo
c'è pure più di pai va bene a salve
tutti contenti di essere sicuro siamo
tutti i nani o questa porta un po
sproporzionata metri a naro calci rossi
di stankovic 6 più di file insegna
quanto pago per tre album head of the
stone sound of silence hai sentito il
suono delle sirene
eri troppo da rilavorare d'ingresso non
so cosa è successo quel giorno cosa è
successo ai ragazzi ai tuoi amici allo
stalker maledetto ha sentito solo
l'ambulanza va bene che tra ma se abiti
non a casa dove gli alberi ti entrano
dentro la finestre fatte le due domande
un prof
rifatta i muri la farei volentieri
comunque come che diventa è diventato un
horror di kitchen e resto gioco che non
si capiva sono uscito
quindi non è un orrore in casa che l'ha
mai fatto un metro abiti di fronte a 20
di fronte hai preso la macchina
deficiente questo inverno senti per
favore non parlare non capisco quello
che dici giuro scudo va bene io non
capisco che dice mi parla cercando di
farmi capire la trama ma ne capisco meno
quando parli quindi vale la porta si
apre e se loading ha quindi è un horror
nella scuola va bene max è un horror
perché non si capisce bene un po strano
sto gioco ci sono degli armadietti gli
ar mariti sono fatti con una grafica da
paura il resto no però vabbè sembra un
po della stoffa l'ss un po grigio devo
scoprire cosa è successo ai miei amici
non scoprilo subito soprattutto perché
ci sono dei divani nel corridoio di una
scuola questa è una cosa che un po mi
turba però davanti l'erba il giardiniere
che come la sua fatta cresce l'erba
dentro la scuola come possibile con che
fisica vetri rotti
bella la palestra
fate pure come se fosse a casa vostra
amica banche
[Musica]
è un horror adesso l'ho capito adesso le
norme prima non l'avevo capito bambino
va be basta già c'è jump square non ne
voglio più ma che lager
a me non è la scuola c'è questa roba
filo spinato ma siete scemi messo a o b
9 dove stiamo ragazzi ci siamo al d9
andrei anche via cioè nel senso non è
che stiamo qua un cammello cinema con
sedie moderne è successo
[Musica]
guardiamo il film va bene cos'è massimo
boldi non è massimo boldi non c'è più ma
mi spunta qualcuno lo so io
no è spento adesso
che io parlo parlo a cosa parlo a fare
io cosa parlo fare
sì il momento ricorrere questo è giusto
ecco che questo è il momento di tutto
nero cavalca copre via via virya mamma
mia è brutto
già questa porta non si apre si apre
niente ecco questa è aperta ai denti
locker
ok che è brutto sto bambino mamma sei
veramente bello andato posso uscire bene
[Musica]
che bello questo era un po che non
giocava un horror fatto bene cos'è starò
alla piscina media e scuola è questa per
posta informazione la canzone non so
perché sei araba è stata incisa da
ciccio nerino e marco o left conto tu
crouch
magari voi lo sapevate già ve lo dico
perché è vip onde evitare copyright mi
spunta un topo gigantesco e meglio del
bambino guarda ben sapete qual è bye bye
bye
la vacca che palle la che violenza ma io
ho camminato tutto sdraiato in quel modo
per tutto il tempo ma dove stiamo
andando lì preciso che non ho capito ma
ha un obiettivo quanto è grosso a scuola
questa non è rihanna cosa mi dice che
questo gioco è un horror ma non ne sono
ancora tanto sicuro bello sgabuzzino
dove vado cosa faccio perché esiste
datemi una mano o c'è un proiettore
prendiamo il film di prima vuoi sapere
come sono morti no ti farò vedere ma ho
detto no no voi se vuoi uscire di qua io
mi interessa sono morti coi loro devo
scendere è volato era volato un culo
giuro chiusa era poi roba lì
se però dovete stare calmi tutti
prendete delle tisane vi prego
ma io devo tornare al cinema adesso c'è
dovrei fare tutto indietro dove c'era il
bambino tutto vi siete pazzi comunque
ricami tutto il giorno 20 mag
c'è una torcia io mi chiamo dice adesso
dalla fine gioco
siete scemi tranquillo non mi dire
niente per carità c'è satana quindi
spinge giù dalle scale e io avevo una
torcia nel deretano lo so cos'è
testarolo non ha bisogno dagli usa
grazie e portato al cinema è portato al
cinema
cos'è
sono i miei amici questi sono prodotti
grava qui sembro io da dietro quando hai
capelli lunghi
[Musica]
noi non l'accetto lega così come sono
morti melo almeno mi ha fatto una
paperella di due ore come sono morti
come sono morti che ne so e fanno amava
fatto vedere ad ora con questo carampana
questo era file a solution soluzione
finale gioco di bambini stalker quindi
ragazzoni spero che vi sia piaciuto come
si è riuscita con te mi piace che vari
social come il dottor nella descrizione
sentiti
iscrivetevi sto telecomando non si ha
ancora rotto in tutto sto tempo e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video dai ragazzi
[Musica]